[Applaudissements]
mettez moi mais ça le shérif metellus
halluciné je suis excité il a la classe
est nommé au lit je te jugent toujours
vrai je suis sous le choc qui folie des
allées ont regardé et là je sais pas
pourquoi ça c'est ouais c'est que j'ai
pas compris la raison regarde très bon
et montagne ça très mauvais montage et
en plus on en a eu une ensemble vocal
l'amfar à cannes à l'amfar ya deux trois
fois à cannes
ouais sur marne est actuellement de tp
annoncé sa venue chaque séquence était à
3 ans la dame force et 4 et à 3,81
talons c'est déjà sa venue dans tpm
péter mena parce qu'aujourd'hui en noir
et blanc il sort des vieilles photos
bientôt les anciennes photos et vidéos
je suis fou de kim kardashian et je suis
fou d'elle je suis fou d'elle devrait
donc si tu la vois tu dis hanouna like
you ya encore d'autres photos là à voir
de mon instinct ou pas oui batani m'a
aussi des mares neymar garde neymar
démarre laborieusement aussi j'adorais
le produit contenant les gouttes ou
lilas et il faut la battu justine
médecins m'ont dit que les couturiers
sont un peu prétentieux et sont snobs
ils sont déconnectés nom est ce que
j'aime justement choses et dire qu'il
est aussi bien à l'aise avec neymar que
ici moi j'étais avec rachid kiabi
[Rires]
je te jure que je pensais quand on
appuie sur c'est une petite surprise
pour toi ballon c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
par ailleurs surpris tout pour moi c'est
quoi mais j'ai des potes qui voulait
dire bonjour des potes est pas tant l
écoute des potes j'ai pas non plus
revenir dans la régie ça marche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu m'aimes pas d'en découdre avec eux
[Applaudissements]
essai
pour m
[Applaudissements]
mettez là mais ça ne sait rien
mais je suis excité et je suis fan
j'adore ça elle est magnifique en pleine
voie là et j'espère qu'il ira nous voir
un jour et je suis ses aventures de ces
voix là je la vois je les aurai c'est un
très beau cadeau aux fans et neymar
[Applaudissements]
wonder boy aller le voir
lee
[Musique]